acclamé par les klaxons les véhicules
blindés de l'armée azérie font leur
entrée dans le district d'agdam sans
combattre l'azerbaïdjan reprend le
contrôle de ce territoire désertée par
ses habitants arménien à la plupart ont
choisi de brûler leur maison pour ne
rien laisser derrière eux
après s'être félicité de la reconquête
le président azerbaïdjanais a appelé les
forces arméniennes à ne pas reprendre
les combats que l'hostilité cesse
maintenant et que des relations
économiques normales soit établie quoi
qu'il en soit c'est ce que nous voulons
je les ai répétés durant la guerre nous
n'avons aucun problème avec le top
arménien nous n'avons procédé à aucun
nettoyage ethnique mais à l'air trop le
peuple arménien mais ils l'ont fait
contre le marcheur après la reprise de
cinq districts l'armée de bakou doit
désormais récupéré deux autres
territoires
le district de kelbadjar le 25 novembre
prochain et celui de latchine le 1er
décembre c'est reconquête découle de
l'accord de paix signé sous l'égide de
la russie pour mettre un terme à six
semaines de combats pour assurer le
respect du cessez le feu
moscou a déployé près de 2000 soldats
une opération qui a permis de stabiliser
la situation selon les propres mots de
vladimir poutine
des soldats turcs devraient aussi
participer à ces opérations selon le
ministre russe de la défense
dans le cadre de la mise en oeuvre du
mémorandum sur la création d'un centre
conjoint russo turque sur le territoire
de l'azerbaïdjan pour contrôler le
respect du cessez-le-feu
la partie turque ihh est actuellement en
train de définir son lieu de déploiement
ainsi que ses prérogatives loi de ces
tractations diplomatiques
une poignée d'opposants arménien à
manifester dans le centre d'erevan
des dizaines de personnes ont ainsi
appelé le premier ministre nikol
pashinian a démissionné le qualifiant de
traître
85 personnes auraient été arrêtées selon
la police locale